I had the idea about two years ago I had
never written an original screenplay so
I wanted to do something that I really
cared a lot about which I decided was
American identity and long before
natural gas ever came into the picture I
guess I subconsciously based it on my
dad who grew up at a steel mill town
just outside of Pittsburgh and called
natrona heights and like any industry
town it had fallen on hard times his dad
worked a lot of multiple jobs and they
didn't have much and I remember being a
very ignorant kid and saying so was your
childhood awful and he said no quite the
opposite it was an incredible community
and a sense of unity and strength and
being there for each other but there was
this faith that tomorrow would be a
better day and I just felt like that I
deal on that version of America we've
moved so far away from so I wanted to
tell the story about communities like
that that obviously still exists and
have a pride in a in a in an amazing
sense of community and so I brought that
idea to Dave Eggers at the time who we
had done away we go together and I known
Dave through many charity events for his
charity 826 and we just kind of hammered
out structure and character because
these issues are very important to him
too he he was white writing one of those
pesky novels that he happens to write a
bunch of and so he couldn't write the
script so I brought the idea to Matt and
and Matt was looking to direct at the
time and I brought him this idea and we
started writing right away John was
doing his show the office we were both
moonlighting and and really we wrote on
weekends he'd show up around breakfast
time on saturday morning and and and we
get to work and and it was so
compartmentalized that that that it
wasn't really hard to do two things at
once I'm I have four kids now so I'm
getting better at multitasking I don't
know how he got the work done though
because between putting the little
mermaid in 17 times and making lunch and
like bathing children I don't know how
we got anything I knew John was it was a
great writing partner when he's offering
dialogue suggestions while giving one of
my kids a horsey ride
either we acted fast just to make it in
time for this year or we since Matt
worked the summertime we shot later and
the film would come out like a year and
a half later or next next season and
because of the topical nature of the
issue we thought it was better sooner
and it was plenty of time it was I think
plenty of time for guests it's like well
week scheduled for format and then Gus
took a while I was the budget and he was
like yeah I'll shoot it in six weeks
more like when Warner's was backing the
movie I remember having conversations
saying you know guys I mean I need at
least 45 days to do this thing are you
kidding me i mean you know Gus did it in
30 you know one of the big benefits for
me was that I prepared it as a director
and and then got to watch the decisions
that Gus made and there were things that
he did just like on Good Will Hunting
that you know we hadn't thought of when
we wrote it and and one of them on the
second day one of one of my favorite
shots in the film happened on day two of
shooting which was the first day that I
went to pitch the lease to Tim guineas
character and Tim Tim was the first
farmer that I meet he's got the
beautiful little daughter with the
golden curly hair and and and we go into
his house and I start to pitch this
lease to him and and we got in there and
Gus took the little girl and she was
like six or seven years old and gave her
a coloring book and Satre at the kitchen
table and like any kid I mean it's just
great because a kid that age gets a task
and they just start you know they
diligently said about doing it she
starts coloring in the coloring book and
she just forgot about the camera and we
were staged in the other room so so
she's very prominent in the foreground
the cameras about five or six feet away
from her and then passed her you see the
doorway in the other room and you see
her father tim guinee character you know
this destitute farmer and then you see
my character the land man but you only
see his hands in the clipboard because
the door frame is cutting it
so so she's in the foreground kind of
dutifully coloring in a coloring book
oblivious to the fact that behind her
back in the other room the generation
for the previous generation the
grown-ups are cutting a deal that's
going to have a huge impact on her life
one way or another and she's just
completely innocent in the foreground
and the camera slowly just starts to
push and I just looked at that fret and
I just went well you know John and I
said well we wrote the thing and we
never thought of had and it was just it
was a perfect visual expression of the
entire idea and and it's just what great
directing is